enscape is finally available on the Mac
and in particular it's actually now
available on the Apple silicon ecosystem
what's going on guys my name is David
Thomas I'm a registered architect here
in Western Australia and like I
mentioned today we're going to be
comparing enscape against twin motion
we're going to be looking at both
packages as a very raw example if you're
a beginner that's never used either of
these two packages I want to just
showcase how simple it is to get a 3D
render completely done in a matter of
minutes and what results you're going to
get without having to go too deep into
the program one of these is absolutely a
clear winner so let's turn around to
this screen and get started with today's
tutorial so now we have our model open
in archicad and we also have it open in
SketchUp now the reason for the fact
that we have these two projects open in
two different softwares is simply
because at the moment enscape is only
compatible through SketchUp so you can
export your file from arcad into
SketchUp and then use it that way
however twin motion on the other hand is
running natively with archicad at the
moment as we speak so we're going to be
comparing archicad with twin motion and
SketchUp with enscape and then comparing
the two as they stand so as you can see
archicad produces everything we always
have been able to do when we take that
into twin motion from the start you're
going to get something like this
straight out of the box now personally I
think that this image right here looks
worse than what it looks like in
archicad if you're going to open up this
twin motion image alone and actually
just render it out as it stands it's
probably not going to be the best image
that is available to you you're going to
have to do a lot of work to make this
image look half decent what I want to
compare today is Straight Out of the Box
how quickly and how easily can we
produce a high quality render without
too much input from ourselves so if
we'll come across down here to the
bottom to Media go to image and create
our first image it'll automatically
punch that image in let's save it and
we're going to try export this image all
the way to 4 okay the best resolution we
can compare it to against in inscape so
we're going to leave all the settings as
they are we're not going to touch
absolutely anything we're going to come
across the export and let's simply just
export this one image to our desktop and
compare it with inscape from an
exporting point of view it takes about
two to three seconds to export an image
of this caliber without anything over
the top which is pretty good there is no
complaints for me to export this image
in export time we are running an Apple
Mac Studio with the Apple M1 Ultra
chipset in it so it should be pretty
quick regardless of what it actually is
now let's jump across the SketchUp first
of all SketchUp completely different
program and my skill set in SketchUp is
very limited so I've been an arcad user
for a long long time I haven't used
SketchUp in about a decade but as we can
see the model is significantly worse
there's a lot more more polygons and
it's just a completely different setup
it has been able to convert that arcad
model into SketchUp very simply very
easily without anything going completely
wrong so even if I was to Simply model
everything in our CAD move it across the
SketchUp then I could actually render it
out in enscape now this is where it gets
actually interesting from my point of
view I personally believe that enscape
was a worse product and produced worse
renders and especially on an Apple
product however if we open up enscape
we're going to see that this is the
default image that has come out directly
from SketchUp I haven't touched anything
I haven't created grass I haven't
imported any materials whatsoever all
I've done is slightly adjust the time so
it's actually daytime because this
started as a nighttime scene but
otherwise I have not done anything to
this image you can also see as I move
around it's automatically trying to
rasterize this image and create some
sort of array tracing path tracing I
don't know what's going on in the
background but it is trying really
really hard you can obviously tell I've
just downloaded a trial for this version
to check out how it works and to
actually test it properly now from first
glance this looks amazing and if we go
into my settings come across the output
I'm going to export this as Ultra HD so
once again 4K leave the rest of these
items by default and close that off next
we're going to come across to our screen
capture and just allow that to export
directly to the desktop this is going to
take again maybe about three to five
seconds so it definitely takes a little
bit longer to actually export this image
compared to Twin motion but I do believe
we're going to get a significantly
better image so let's go ahead and
compare these two images so as you can
see now we have both images open on the
left and the right the left is Twin
motion and the right is obviously
enscape with that big massive trial logo
version on it so what we can see is
automatically one that the Shadows is
significantly better deeper and richer
the contrast the colors is all there
this image you could almost render out
without having to touch anything which
means it's going to be a significantly
easier process you can even see that it
started to do quite a bit of decent
reflection into these windows up the top
whereas there is no reflection in this
and you can see completely through the
house overall I think if you're going to
spend some time low learning how to
master either of these two programs
hopefully once enscape is available on
archicad and with the Apple silicon
chipsets this is going to be an
extremely powerful program until twin
motion does something to catch up very
rapidly anyway that's all for me today
guys thank you so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed the video if you did
make sure you smash that subscribe
button down below but like always I'll
see you next Monday